it turns out ladies gentlemen that
Ravens have emotional empathy this is
real yes a new academic study finds that
Ravens are capable of spreading negative
emotions to their friends this blew me
away it's pretty remarkable
Ravens can spread negative emotions even
more remarkable is how they do it
for instance they do it by fat shaming
each other for eating too many worms
commenting you suck on another Ravens
Instagram post putting out a dollar in a
string when another Ribbon goes to the
string and jerking it away posting a
one-star yelp review for a restaurant
they've never been to loudly sighing
during a friend's one-man show and
finally writing gossip about a co-worker
on the bathroom wall
you